[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 el
senado de méxico aprobó la ley olimpia
para tipificar delitos relacionados con
acoso digital especialmente los que
tienen que ver con la difusión de
contenido íntimo y sexual la reforma
implicaría a penas de hasta seis años de
cárcel y ahora se espera que pase de
nuevo a la cámara de diputados con el
objetivo de que las normas que ya se
habían aprobado en la mayoría de estados
del país se extiendan a niveles federal
la llamada ley olimpia califica como
violencia digital toda acción dolosa
realizada mediante el uso de tecnologías
de la información por la que se exponga
y se difundan imágenes audios o vídeos
de contenido íntimo sexual de una
persona sin su consentimiento
olimpia es el nombre de la activista del
estado de puebla que inició esta lucha a
nivel nacional en 2014 después de ser
víctima de violencia digital a sus 18
años
-mario carbonell le tiene la historia
desde ciudad de mexico
[Música]
[Aplausos]
olimpia coral vivió una pesadilla en su
natal puebla cuando un video sexual suyo
se subió en las redes sociales sin su
consentimiento se viralizó y dañó su
dignidad y todos los días
deseaba amanecer muerta todos los días
mi mamá no sabía y mi familia cercana no
lo sabía
mi mamá pensaba que yo estaba encerrada
y deprimida porque había terminado con
mi ex novio no sabía que es porque
habían difundido un vídeo sexual a raíz
de ello la entonces chica de 18 años
decidió emprender una lucha para que se
apruebe lo que se dio en llamar la ley
olimpia que implica sanciones de hasta
seis años de cárcel por producir y
difundir imágenes íntimas en internet
sin autorización la primera vez que subí
esta reforma fue estás loca eso no se
puede hacer
[Música]
a la fecha los congresos de 27 estados
han aprobado la ley olimpia y el 5 de
noviembre lo hizo el senado de la
república la senadora malú mícher
presidente de la comisión de igualdad de
género fue ella misma víctima de
violencia digital y considera que esta
ley era una deuda pero además señala que
en el senado le incorporaron al código
penal la violencia en medios de
comunicación que cosifica y
estereotipada la mujer entonces quien
distribuya quien utilice quien difunda
imágenes nuestras o también o legitimen
la violencia contra las mujeres el
sexismo la discriminación contra las
mujeres y las niñas está cometiendo el
delito de violencia mediática se espera
que la ley sea ratificada por los
diputados en breve y en adelante estará
en la cancha del poder judicial
olimpia y sus compañeras seguirán
presionando para que los cinco congresos
estatales faltantes aprueben la ley y
sobre todo para crear conciencia sobre
este tipo de violencia que no sólo es
virtual sino bien real
vamos a conversar precisamente con la
creadora de esta iniciativa olimpia
coral m lo quien es además la
protagonista de nuestra historia de hoy
olimpia bienvenida a france24 bienvenida
de ella soy y como se reformó la
propuesta que han llevado hasta el
congreso para que pasara por el senado y
cómo seguirá el proceso para que se
convierta en ley federal
bueno es todavía un poquito difícil
todavía tiene que llegar al congreso a
la cámara de diputados- y tiene que
aprobarse ahí mismo en la cámara de
diputados después tiene que ratificarse
por parte del presidente de la república
para una vez ya que no haya ningún
cambio sea publicada y pues sí sí ha
sido todo todo un transcurso de lucha
constante desde muchas cuestiones en las
que nosotras y mis compañeras todas
juntas pues hemos no ha parado desde
hace ya varios años claro sí es un
proceso largo no es sencillo pero hay
que reconocerle olimpia que después de
haber trabajado desde el año 2014 ya
haber llegado a esta instancia y sobre
todo ver que la mayoría de estados
mexicanos han tomado acción en contra
del acoso digital pues es un avance
grande de eso vamos a hablar un poco más
adelante pero antes quisiera que usted
nos dijera de primera mano como una
víctima de este tipo de violencias por
qué es importante legitimar que esto es
también una forma de ejercer machismo
que es más que un mal chiste o jugarle
una mala pasada a otra persona
bueno lo que pasa es que hasta antes de
esta reforma en mi país en mexico no se
reconocía la violencia digital como una
violencia real o sea se cree que como es
virtual no es real no pasa nada y aunque
como no puedes ver una agresión pues
entonces no existe la agresión y
nosotras hemos luchado principalmente
para que las mentes de todas las
personas incluso hablemos de mexico al
mundo que lo virtual es real que existe
que daña que cada like que cada
compartir que cada vez que infunden
nuestros cuerpos principalmente sin
nuestro consentimiento es una violencia
no y además olimpia que no hay un
contacto físico pero el golpe si se
siente las consecuencias si se sienten
cuáles son esas secuelas de las víctimas
de estos tipos de violencia y además en
la imposibilidad hasta el momento en la
mayoría de los casos de reclamar
justicia y dignificación
claro es que es como si te violaran sin
penetrar cada vez que le dan like cada
vez que difunden cada vez que toman tu
cuerpo tu vídeo en mi caso por ejemplo
cuando publicaron este vídeo sexual es
osea yo sentí como si me estuvieran
violando cada persona que compartía ese
vídeo que yo no autoricé que se
difundiera cada persona que le daba like
a persona que comentara no importaba si
ellos lo habían publicado o no seguían
la cadena de acoso y cuando es virtual
se pone al escrutinio ciudadano en las
manos de todas las personas es a
revictimización esa señalización y como
hay un tabú sobre nuestros cuerpos
desnudo sobre todas las mujeres algo que
que no le pasa a los hombres por ejemplo
es
esta cuestión del consumo de nuestros
cuerpos al placer sexual de una cultura
cuerdo y eso agrava y perpetuar lo que
estamos viviendo es como como si
salieran a la calle desnuda y todo el
mundo te golpeara y todo el mundo te
atacarán no sabes que hiciste mal y
además todo mundo te culpe a ti porque
tú te dejaste grabar porque tú lo
hiciste hoy esas locas a las que
llamaban locas que nos decían les
vivimos en decir en mi país a vernos no
estamos locas y debemos tener derecho a
tener una vida íntima respetada el hecho
de que yo haga sexy no significa que las
personas tengan derecho a publicarlos y
con mi consentimiento porque al igual
que el sexo es consensuado y si no es
violación en el espacio virtual también
si no hay consenso es violación
violación de la intimidad sexual y hoy
ya no es porque lo digamos nosotras hoy
se castiga hasta con seis años de cárcel
y hay muchos retos importantísimos en un
país donde tiene más del 80% de
impunidad
la reforma no es la panacea pero sí es
el cambio de raíz e incluso nosotros
hemos luchado por que se le deje decir
por no venganza no es por no ni es
venganza porque decirle pues no es
volver a normalizar la cultura por no
del placer sector masculino sobre
nuestros cuerpos y venganza es re
victimizarnos algo insiste tout alguno
terminó con el novio es como decir a una
mujer te acusaron seguro boquete a la
espalda es re victimizante entonces para
asustar la ley o limpiar más allá que un
texto era muy fácil algo por agarrar
obviar y subir a los estados pero es más
allá de eso de nada nos sirve incluso en
otros países comenzarán a subir esta
reforma copiando el modelo de méxico si
no entienden de raíz lo que está pasando
si no entienden de raíz que césar en la
educación digital la educación sexual el
abrir las conciencias para dejar de
consumir los cuerpos de las mujeres como
si fuéramos simplemente objetos y no
sujetas de derecho entonces es más allá
que de una reforma insultar lo que
queremos es que podamos estar seguras
también es dictar que nos sentamos
seguras de sí y además es que hay un
tema aquí de conciencia y es que
en muchísimos casos olimpia los abusos y
la violencia machista nace de una
relación de poder y no de una sexualidad
consensuada como lo que usted está
planteando entonces en ese sentido yo
quisiera preguntarle usted qué es lo que
recomienda para que las personas porque
además pues no solamente podemos decir
que las mujeres son víctimas si bien son
la mayoría de víctimas en estos casos se
recomienda para que la gente evite
convertirse en una víctima más de estos
delitos digitales bueno son 22
recomendaciones a dos públicos
diferentes no el primero es precisamente
a los consumidores porque sin clientes
no hay trata o sea por más y más y más
que les digamos a las mujeres no hagas
esto es otra vez volver a dirigir la
responsabilidad a nosotras no a nueve de
cada diez casos perpetua dos son por sus
parejas y exparejas por unas conocidas
actualmente sus novios y ex parejas eso
no significa que todos sean iguales
significa que hay que hacernos
responsables gustos de de esa magnitud
del problema
desgraciadamente en nueve de cada diez
víctimas somos mujeres
en mi país más de 9 millones de mujeres
hemos vivido algún tipo de ciberacoso
sin contar además aquellos que no se han
visto y no se pueden tener cifras pero
más allá de la cifra es es una
utilización completa de nuestros cuerpos
de la infra sexualización entonces a los
caballeros mientras tú estás porque todo
el mundo ve un pacto sea si hiciéramos
ahorita un análisis en noticiarios hasta
que no celulares todos piensen en las
últimas imágenes que les llegaron
seguramente entre ellas hay fotografías
de mujeres desnudas conocen sus caras
conocen sus cuerpos cuando ven esas
fotografías desnudas pero no conocen la
historia que hay detrás de samper no
sabe si esa mujer puede ser víctima de
trata no sabe si esa mujer difundieron
ese vídeo que te mandó tu cuate sin su
consentimiento o esa mujer puede estar
muerta o suicidándose al mismo vez a la
misma vez que tus atiende placer poner
ese vídeo como utiliza jacqueline en el
estado de coahuila que es arduo con el
cable de teléfono en su baño mientras
una persona estaba viendo su fotografía
íntima entonces va dirigido primero años
que hacer para evitar que haya una
víctima de violencia que nos sigan
consumiendo nuestros cuerpos
objetos sexuales y que piensen cada vez
que cada vez que les mandan un pack sus
compañeros sus amigos en los grupos que
paren que prende esa cadena porque cada
la ética compartida es un ciber golpe a
una mujer y cada vez que usted ya lo
está normalizando poder estar asesinando
a una persona y podrían estarse también
convirtiendo entre mini citas a través
de los espacios digitalizados y fue al
otro lado a las personas que quieran
hacer sexting que lo hagan en
condiciones seguras que se cuestionen
todo que no confíen a la primera vez que
no confían en personas que no conocen
para hacer sexting que lo hagan a través
de redes sociales seguras wicker
occidente telegram que no se vean nunca
su rostro que no se vea nunca su cara
que no haya algo que las identifique que
los identifique que si ya saben todas
las funciones del sexting bueno que
sepan que en una internet que a veces es
patriarcal o la mayoría de veces para
acercar es casi imposible hablar de
sexting seguro pero si hay medidas de
seguridad para hacerlo lo menos inseguro
o si olimpia muchas gracias por su
participación gracias por la iniciativa
que adelanta que seguro nos va a ser
útil a las mujeres en américa latina
y para finalizar el cuerpo de la mujer
no es un objeto de consumo y la
violencia digital también nos mata siga
con nosotros en france 24
[Música]